oo weee, big storm coming
could be a twister hmm hey Rick can you
walk me through something here what are
you thinking
so you and Morty knew you needed my help but you weren't sure I was good enough
at karate so you hired my grad students
to attack me yep but it was an emergency
Rick how long did that take it actually
took less training than you'd think
your students all shared a pretty keen
aptitude for martial arts I don't know
if that's by coincidence or if there's
some correlation with their passion for
african-american women's studies Maya
Angelou did personify both acquiescence
and perseverance to explore in my class
too bad I lost my job for putting my
students in the hospital yeah yeah sorry
about that it seems like a good time for
a drink and a cold calculated speech
with sinister overtones a speech about
politics about order Brotherhood power
but speeches are for campaigning now is
the time for action welcome back
everyone it's Charlie this is going to
be my new Rick and Morty season 4
episode 3 video for the post-credits
scene and evil Morty I know there a lot of big questions about where he is what is he
doing right now when are we going to see
him on the show again so if you're new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the easter egg videos we're
doing a weekly merch giveaway - all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your best season for evil
Morty theory on the video so careful for
spoilers for everything that's happened
on the show so far but in this post
credit scene at the beginning they
reference a storm coming big storm
coming and it's going to be a twister as
in a big twist Rick in the former
professor poopy butthole we'll talk
about the logic behind the story of this
week's episode in a meta way while Morty
in the background solves this Rubik's
Cube with a very distant very severe
evil Morty esque look on his face you
can see in here this giant storm coming
in the distance and it gives the scene a
very ominous cast to it portents of very
bad things to come the whole joke about
the relationship between Maya Angelou
though and knowing martial arts is
because the students were so interested
in her that they themselves tried to
embody her ideas as Rick says
perseverance and acquiescence
acquiescence in the sense that they
would submit themselves to sitting in
his classroom all day to learn about her
in perseverance in that they had learned
to defend themselves and take action
when they felt threatened then the joke
with him directly referencing the idea
that he lost his job because it's
totally not okay to fight with your
students so a lot of you in the last
couple of episodes have asked why
haven't we seen evil Morty yet or any
direct on-screen references to him
beyond the more subtle ones when they
start referencing the events of season
three and everything that Rick did that
led them to change their family dynamic
there was a clip with one of the writers
from episode 3 talking about being brand
new to the Rick and Morty writers room
at the start of this new 70 episode
order and how they had all this content
that they had to produce in how the
producers including dan and Justin gave
them some basic guidelines in terms of
what kinds of references and ideas for
episodes they were supposed to generate
for this first block of episodes are
they're forbidden topics are there
hackie topics frequently pitched ideas
things to avoid
we were not encouraged to go back and
like find another meeseeks episode
because that's just to to tunnel vision
for finding a good episode of the show
and probably because there's 70 episode
left of the show it's like you don't
want to go back to the well necessarily
there is so much more to find and more
to create that you know don't narrow
your view by thinking well what do I
have to go back and answer and like
there's time for all that stuff so one
of the examples that she gives is that
Dan and Justin the other producers
didn't want the writers going to look
for extra meeseeks episodes because they didn't want them mining old bits over
and over again there were 70 episodes
that they had to fill dan and Justin
aren't huge fans of totally ripping
themselves off particularly this early
in the run that doesn't mean that
they'll never bring stuff back and there
were meeseeks during the first episode
that's them being cool with subtle
references and jokes about earlier bits
that's why you saw a very short but very
big meeseeks scene you saw a pickle Rick you saw squatchy in their visions all
bits from previous episodes in the past
but a lot of them were quick and hard to
spot if you weren't watching the episode
really carefully so they weren't super
on the knows about some of those
callbacks and even with the meeseeks one
which was a little more over the
producer explained that the whole idea
was the meeseeks scene was meant to be a reference how derivative in hacky
Morty's ideas are all versions of Morty
not just the main version of Morty
during the episode but also fascist
Morty where he keeps repeating that he
wants to go back to old-fashioned good
old Rick and Morty adventures we're
going back to the way things used to be
so it was the writers making fun of the
Morty character in a meta way making fun
of themselves and calling out a small
portion of the fandom that gets too
obsessed with their older bits the
difference with evil morty though is
that he's not a bit from an earlier
episode he's become one of the cords
serialized elements of the show in
probably one of the biggest adversaries
that rick has been creating for himself
that's also been another recurring theme
in the last couple of episodes like
during episode two the mobster fly that
he threatens when he's looking for the
toilet bandit and he walks away without
killing them and he tells Rick that he's
going to pay for this but then Rick
basically doesn't care he says it'll be
worth it if I find out
who used my toilet the creation of a
whole other new plot thread with a whole
organization of people that want Rick's
blood and even though they haven't gone
really deep into serialized story
elements in the first three episodes
just remember what they said at the end
of episode one the ending scene where
they start yelling at each other about
the future of Rick and Morty
they said the season four is going to be a
mixture of serialized stories one-offs
like the heist episode in episodes that
were about nothing at all the kind of
joke which to me feels more like a
Seinfeld reference which famously
marketed itself as a show that was about
nothing just a bunch of people hanging
out and funny things happen to them
during the normal course of their day in
fact if you never saw it they actually
have a Seinfeld deleted scene from a
previous episode it didn't make it past
animatic but it's a genuine Seinfeld
scene in a Rick and Morty episode hey
Marty look it's Seinfeld from a
dimension where he's completely
unrelated I'll turn it up Rick what's
the deal with all these Mexican bones
under our house why do we keep burying
Mexicans in the basement I mean what's
the deal with these Mexican bones
they're so hard to eat boy you know Rick
I never found Seinfeld funny but this
stuff really gets me yeah you know Morty
I think we finally found a Seinfeld for
our generation okay cool okay
ultra specific references like that feel
like they come from Dan more than they
come from Justin but if you missed a lot
of the coverage of Rick and Morty season
4 during comic-con this summer there was a clip of them talking about a special
moment that would happen during a
post-credits scene in the first five
episodes of season 4 there would be a
big teaser for things to come now that's
not them coming right out and saying
they're definitely doing an evil Morty
post-credit scene reference but they are
pretty much saying that outside of the
normal funny stuff that they do in
post-credit scenes and callbacks to
jokes within the particular episodes
they're implying it's supposed to tease
something really big is coming and mr.
poopy butthole says a big storm is
coming Rick says it will be a big
twister as in big twist implying that
they're going to be doing something big
with evil Morty in the second half of
season 4 for those of you asking when
the second block of episodes
err based on Adult Swim's behavior in
the past until they say something
official early guesses that they'll come
back at the end of January right after
the Christmas and New Year's holidays if
you look back at the Rick and Morty
season 1 episode scheduled they did
something very similar breaking that
season into two parts airing the first
half before Christmas in the second half
after Christmas but catching up with
evil Morty at the beginning of season 4
the last we saw him he was beginning to
restructure the Citadel of Rick's
Morty's in general were enjoying more
freedom more power he fired the teachers
that were giving them the old dogma
about how Morty's were supposed to serve
their Rick's but beyond rebuilding the
Citadel itself in creating his Morty new
world order that was about it
Tammy Phoenix person the remnants of the
galactic government are still out there
somewhere
we know squantchy is out there somewhere because there's a future timeline where
he winds up killing Rick for he's all
squashed out but I'm not expecting to
see any of those characters show up
really really soon mostly for the same
reason they're holding off on doing evil
Morty's Citadel stuff right away there's
70 more episodes so they're just going to
ease into some of that stuff but post
all your theories in the comments do you
think that they're gearing up for a big
evil Morty Citadel return in the back
half of season 4 next year big storms
come in quick reminder that episode 4 is
going to be this weekend they were on break
this past weekend for Thanksgiving I
will do no bonus video soon so let me
know what you want that video to be
about congratulations alpha j 3.0 you're
the giveaway winner from my last big
Rick & Morty video please email me on
the about page of my channel so I can
get your details
everyone click here for the Rick and
Morty season 4 episode 4 trailer video
and click here for my new Mandalorian
video about why the Empire wants baby
Yoda so bad thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight!